Transcriber: Emre Incel
Gözden geçirme: Nihal Aksakal
Merhaba.
Saati başlattılar.
Bugün kısa bir konuşmam var.
O yüzden saati rahat kullanmayı
deneyeceğim.
Gözlükle sizi göremiyor olmam
ne demek acaba?
Gözüm düzeldi zannediyorum.
Konuşmama başlamadan önce
biraz sohbet etmek istiyorum.
Çünkü sahne özgür bir alan.
Madem çıktık konuşalım.
Siz de dinlendiniz zannediyorum,
sabahtan beri diğer konuşmaları
dinleye dinleye.
Ben içeride konuşmacıların
bazılarıyla karşılaşabildim.
Günseli Hanım ile karşılaştım.
Ben eskiden beri tanırım kendisini,
çok sevindik birbirimizi gördüğümüze.
Günseli Hanım,
"Ne ile ilgili konuşacaksın?" dedi.
Dedim "Günseli Hanım sizin yanınızda
benim yapacağım konuşma,
osur osur ipe diz gibi bir şey".
O da dedi ki:
"Doğru, son konuşacaksın ya.".
(Kahkaha)
O kadar da değil diyemedim tabii o an.
Neyse tamam hazırsanız başlıyorum.
Evet.
Konuşmamın başlığı "Sen Nerdesin?"
Sonunda anlayacaksınız
neden oraya bağlandığını.
Efendim, ben küçükken
on yaşındayken kolumu kırdım.
Kuzenim ile karate yapıyorduk.
Biz çocukken karate bilmeden,
karate yapmak olmazsa olmazımızdı.
Sadece "puah" dediğimizde
karate yaptığımızı,
düşünüyorduk o zamanlar.
Şey gibi düşünün, dünyayı yöneten
siyasetçiler gibi düşünün.
Hani, yanında torpil patlamadan
Twitter'dan savaş ilan edenler var ya.
Aynen onlar gibiydik.
Biz de yapmaya dair hiçbir fikrimiz
olmayan şeyleri yapıyorduk
ama zararımız kendimize idi.
Onlar gibi değildik.
Neyse, bunu şu an açıklayamam zaten.
Neyse, karate yapıyoruz.
Ben uçan tekme atmaya karar verdim.
Yalnız ben on yaşımdayken
şu andaki kilomdan
on kilo eksiğim ve 1,20 boyundayım.
Yani, pek mümkün değil benim
herhangi bir şeyi uçarak yapmam.
Ama o an bunun farkında değilim tabii.
Uçan tekme atacağım, sıçradım.
Sıçradım dediğim de bu yani.
Öyle bir sıçrama değil.
Sıçradım, tekmeyi çıkardım.
Baktım tekme zannettiğim yere gitmiyor.
"Allah Allah ne oluyor acaba?" derken
böyle bir üç-beş saliselik bir an vardır,
hani tam böyle düşerken falan
çok başına gelir insanın.
Saçma sapan şeyler gelir aklına.
Ya ben mesela geçen sene
motosikletten düştüm.
O zaman da oldu.
Yani motosikletten düşmedim aslında
motosiklet ile düştüm.
Her sabah gittiğim bir yol vardı benim.
Yine o yoldan giderken, bir viraj var.
Oraya girdim. "Aa" dedim tam giremedim
dönemeyeceğim böyle.
"En iyisi, motoru yatırayım,
kökleyeyim gazı." dedim.
Ben gazı kökledim,
saatte 25 km'ye çıktı hızım.
Çünkü motorum 50 cc.
Motora binenler bilir.
25 km hızla yatarsan
labadanak yere düşersin zaten.
Ben de düştüm.
Yalnız düştüğüm anda
düştüğümü fark etmedim.
Böyle önce bir "dınk" etti kask.
"Fıss" diye kayıyorum.
Motor olması gereken yerde değil.
Bacaklarımın arasında.
Gidiyor benden önde.
Bir de çok yatay gidiyoruz.
"Allah Allah, bir şey oluyor ama
ne oluyor acaba?"
falan diye kayıyorum ben böyle.
Kaydım, kaydım, durup ayağa kalkana
kadar anlamadım düştüğümü.
İşte, uçan tekmeyi atarken de
benzer bir şey oluyor.
Gitmedi tekme.
"Allah Allah." dedim.
Şöyle yere doğru baktım.
Yere yaklaşıyorum.
"Haa, yer çekimi." dedim.
Dedim bari elimi koyayım.
Elimi koydum.
Yetmiş kilo o elin üstüne düşünce
zaten kırdı iki kemiği birden.
Bir de biz Arhavi'deyiz o zaman.
Arhavi'de o zaman beton 3 metrekare var.
Geri kalan her yer ağaç yeşillik
falan filan kaynıyor yani doğa.
Biz aptal olduğumuz için gittik
betonda yapıyoruz karateyi de.
Kolumun kırılmasının
etkenlerinden biri de bu.
Neyse biz ne yapacağız
bununla acaba derken,
bir odaya saklandık hemen çünkü
herkes evde şimdi birşey diyecekler,
ama ne diyecekler bilmiyoruz.
Olasılıkları hesaplamaya başladık.
Olasılıklar!
(Kahkaha)
(Alkış)
Olasılıkları hesaplamaya başladık,
ilk hesapladığımız,
aklımıza gelen olasılık şu:
Acaba ölür müyüm?
İkincisi, kuzenimi hapse atarlar mı?
Üçüncüsü, ben bu kolu tek başıma,
kimseye çaktırmadan iyileştirebilir miyim?
Havaya bak!
Dördüncüsü, acaba Allah
bu yer çekiminin belasını verir mi?
Beşincisi, karate hayatıma
ne zaman geri dönebileceğim?
Altıncısı, en zor olanı da bu,
annemle babam ne diyecek?
İnsanı tahmin etmek en zoru zaten.
Hele yakınınızdaysa daha zor,
tahmin edemiyorsunuz, bilemiyorsunuz ki.
Beklediğiniz şeyi
onlara yapıştırıyorsunuz, yerse.
Tabii bu herkes için geçerli değil.
Genelleme severler var.
Birine bakınca
"Aa bu şey tiplerden." diyor.
"Ben biliyorum şey tiplerden,
ne tiplerden acaba?"
Sonra bir de memleketten
kerteriz alanlar var, onlar daha tuhaf.
"O Kongolu, ben biliyorum, Kongolu o,
Kongo'dan adam çıkmaz."
Kongolu ya, nerede gördün sen Kongolu,
74 milyon nüfusu var kaçını gördün acaba?
Bu Kongo sana ne etti yani?
Şimdi zaten soru sormaya ihtiyacımız yok.
Sosyal medya hesaplarımız var.
Hepimiz oralara bakarak birbirimizin,
belki kim olduğunu değil,
ama kim olmak istediğini
tahmin edebiliyoruz.
Kim olmak "istediğini"
Biz bunu tahmin etmeye çalışırken de,
kendimizle ilgili bütün bilgileri,
dünyaya veriveriyoruz.
Biz bunları veriyoruz
ve bizi kaydediyorlar.
Hem de bütün çıplaklığımızla.
Sadece Facebook, sadece Facebook diyorum
ama bütün hepsi kaydediyor.
Sadece Facebook yüz on tane sinyalle,
bizim kim olduğumuzu,
sosyal yatkınlığımızı, zevklerimizi,
neye para harcamayı sevdiğimizi, hatta
siyasal yatkınlığımızı tespit ediyor,
aklında tutuyor,
yeri geldiğinde de satıyor.
Nerdeyse herşeyi bize
unutturmaya çalışan dünya,
bizi unutmamak için kaydediyor.
Hem de ne kaydediyor.
Kendinize o kayıtlardan baksanız,
kendinizle yeniden tanışmanız gerekebilir.
Ama biz seviyoruz, kalpti, like'dı.
Eskiden kumar makineleri vardı,
yandan kollu
"Şak" diye çekiyordun,
"labadalabada" tekerlekler dönüyordu.
Yanyana üç tane çilek gelince
jeton dökülüyordu.
Mutlu oluyorduk.
Şimdi de öyle sosyal medya mecralarında,
çekiyoruz aşağıya
"labadalabada" kalpler geliyor,
tıklar geliyor, like'lar geliyor.
Onlar her geldiğinde
biz dopamin salgılıyoruz.
Varlığımız bir kez daha kanıtlanıyor.
Her tık aldığımızda, bir tık daha
varlığımızı kanıtlamış oluyoruz.
Oh ne güzel!
Ama biz bunlarla uğraşırken,
bizim daha sağlam tüketiciler haline
nasıl getirilebileceğimizin
cevaplarını da yaldır yaldır veriyoruz.
Sonra bu cevapları kaydediyorlar
ve satıyorlar.
Şu an bizi, bizden çok daha iyi tanıyan,
bankalar, markalar ve siyasi partiler var.
Evet.
Verilerimizi vermemek için
ağlaşıp duruyoruz.
Aman verilerimiz çalınmasın diyoruz.
Ama durup durup veriveriyoruz, verileri.
Brezilya ile birlikte dünyada
en çok veri veren ilk beş ülkeden biriyiz.
Neden bu kadar çok baz istasyonu var
etrafta biliyor musunuz?
Çünkü veri gönderiyoruz.
Evet.
Buradayım.
Bunu demeye ihtiyacımız var.
Şuradayım. Şununla birlikteyim.
Ya da şunu yiyorum.
Ya da ben zaten geçen sene de
buradaydım "throwback" yapalım.
Neredesin aşkım?
Buradayım aşkım.
Şuradayım aşkım,
oradayım aşkım, buradayım aşkım.
Bitmiyor bu. Konum at aşkım,
snap at aşkım.
Yalnızlıktan geberiyoruz,
Instagram, Facebook, Twitter yıkılıyor,
story'ler coşuyor, kalpler havada,
snap atmadan duramıyoruz,
retweet yapmadan, yorum yazmadan,
oturamıyoruz.
Verilerimiz kaydolmasın diye yırtınıyoruz,
ama bir selfie ile
kırk yere veri veriyoruz.
Veriveriyoruz.
Tamam sonunda alkışlarsın.
(Kahkaha)
Gelmiyor çünkü arkası.
(Alkış)
Hayır onun için demedim.
Pardon vallahi onun için demedim.
Peki biz neden bu kadar
veri vermeyi seviyoruz,
"veri" vermeyi seviyoruz?
Çünkü kaç tıklandığımızı bilmek istiyoruz.
Biz aslında tıklanmayı seviyoruz.
Benim "Abi yalnız son zamanlarda
beni hiç tıklamıyorsun."
diyen arkadaşım var.
Biz ne zaman bu hale geldik?
Nerdeyiz biz?
Like alayım, Mike'ı bulayım derken
veri paketleri içinde,
kara delikte kaybolduk gittik.
Sen bile senin kim olduğundan
bihabersin ya!
Denetimin dışında
o kadar fazla sen var ki.
O kadar fazla sen var ki,
sen artık hiç kimsesin!
Zaten o kadar
hiç kimse haline gelmiş olmasan,
durup dururken bu kadar çok,
"Sen benim kim olduğumu biliyor musun?"
der miydin?
Adam çakarları takmış arabaya,
şehir eşkiyası gibi geziyor memlekette.
(Araba sesi) (Selektör sesi).
Bir tane çevirme var,
polis durduruyor bunu.
"Geç kardeşim" geçti.
(Açma sesi) camı açtı.
"Ehliyet ruhsayı alabilir miyim?"
"Sen benim kim olduğumu biliyor musun?"
Allah Allah, evladım zaten
ona bakmak için durdurdu ya.
Hem neyin hassasiyeti bu beybisi?
Kişisel verini mi gizleyeceksin?
(Kahkaha)
On beş dakika önce verdin ya
kebapçıda bir buçuk Adanayla,
şak diye oturttun ya o fotografı.
Konum var, kişisel veri var,
o var bu var,
o Adananın fiyatını biz biliyoruz.
Hayırdır? Nerdesin sen?
Zaten biz böyle kişisel verilerimizi
vermeyelim diye debelenirken,
adama sormazlar mı?
Dünyayla ilgili
bu kadar veri verdik eline ne yaptın?
Sormazlar.
Sormuyorlar.
Mesela al sana veri.
Denizlerimizdeki balıkların %20'sinde
mikro plastiğe rastlanmış.
Bu ne demek biliyor musunuz?
Yediğimiz beş balıktan
bir tanesinde plastik olabilir.
Hani nerdesin?
Hidroelektrik santraller,
yaptılar derelere, nehirlere.
Enerjiyle mi ilgiliydi acaba?
Yoksa yer üstü su kaynaklarının
tamamını depolanabilir hale getirip
yeraltı su kaynaklarını
kullanıma açmak için miydi?
Dağdan gelen, Allah'ın suyunun
başına çeşmeyi koyup
onun da başına
birini oturtabilmek için miydi?
Hani nerdesin?
Al sana veri gibi veri.
Nisan ayına kadar, 2018 yılında,
şiddet cinayetine,
kurban giden kadın sayısı
seksen üç!
"Anıt Sayaç" diye bir internet sitesi var,
isimlerine oradan bakabilirsiniz.
Arkadaşlar, nisan ayına kadar
zaten doksan gün var.
Bu ne demek farkında mısınız?
İstanbul Anlaşması vardı?
2011'de imzaladık.
6284 sayılı Koruma Kanunu var.
Ne oldu?
Koruyamadık mı?
Evet. Nerdesin?
Ben geçen ay, Kadın Cinayetlerini
Önleme Platformu genel temsilcisi,
Doktor Gülsüm Kav'la bir röportaj yaptım.
Öğrendiğim bir çok şeyi de
ondan öğrendim, bu konuyla ilgili.
Kadın Cinayetlerini Önleme Platformu
bu cinayetleri önlemek için,
bir çok şey yapıyor.
Artı olarak da,
bu cinayetlere kurban giden
kadınların davalarını takip ediyorlar.
Gülsüm Hanım'ın anlattığı şeylerden
benim en çok ilgimi çeken şey şu oldu:
Bu davalardaki zanlıların, sanıkların
iki tane benzeşen özellikleri var.
Bir tanesi, hepsi mahkemeye
ceket kravatla gidiyor,
iyi hal indiriminden faydalanmak için,
efendi görünmek için.
Halk arasında zaten iyi hal indirimine
ceket kravat indirimi diyorlar.
İkinci ve bana daha enteresan
gelense şuydu:
Hepsi, öldürdükleri kadınlar için
kötü kadın tarif ediyorlar.
Yani onları aldattıklarını,
başkalarıyla birlikte olduklarını
ve bununla alakalı
bilumum şey tarif ediyorlar.
Ne oldu? Ölenin arkasından
kötü konuşmuyorduk biz.
Daha da enteresanı, Gülsüm Hanım'ın
şahit olduğu davaların
sadece bir tanesinde
bir hakim çıkıp şunu söylüyor:
"Bu anlattıklarınız
sadece boşanma sebebi olabilir.
Cinayet sebebi asla olamaz."
Yalnızca bir tanesi!
Belki Gülsüm Hanım'ın karşılaşmadığı
başka davalarda daha fazladır bu sayı.
Ama neden hepsi değil?
Niye değil?
Evet? Nerdesin?
Peki biz nerdeyiz?
Sahiden soruyorum bunu.
Biz şu an nerdeyiz? Bir salonda mıyız?
Bir sahnede miyiz?
Yoksa bir ekranda mıyız?
Youtube'da mıyız?
Hayır Youtube'daysak şunu yapmam lazım.
(Elindeki şişeyi havaya atar, poz verir)
Nerdeyiz gerçekten?
Yoksa biz, daracık bir tuvalette,
bir yeni yetmenin,
cep telefonu ekranında mıyız?
Hepimiz kalktık giyindik, süslendik,
buraya geldik.
İçeride aylarca bu organizasyonu
yapmak için debelenmiş arkadaşlar var.
Siz bir tam gününüzü bizi seyretmek için,
bizi dinlemek ve bu deneyimi,
bizimle paylaşmak için harcadınız.
Biz, konuşmacılar, haftalarca
bu konuşmaları hazırlamak,
sizinle paylaşmak için çalıştık.
Biz şu an tuvalet ekranında mıyız?
Biz neredeyiz?
Ben size söyleyeyim.
Cennetin eksi ikinci katındayız!
Hoş geldiniz, iyi akşamlar.
(Alkış)